Gençler merhaba. Hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
9. sınıfın son konusu olan hücre zarı ve
madde alışverişlerinden bahsedeceğiz.
Şimdi birçok öğrencinin zorlandığı konu
biliyorum. Kendimden biliyorum. Çünkü
ben de zamanında 9. sınıf oldum değil
mi? Eğer yapamıyorsan çok da panik
yapma. Yapabiliyorsan zaten helal olsun.
Ya hocam yapamıyorsak helal olsun değil
mi? Sana da helal olsun ama
öğrenilmeyecek bir konu değil. Şimdi ne
yap biliyor musun? Bir tane kağıt kalem
al. Şöyle dersin gidişatında ne
yapacağız? Bir onu görelim. O kağıt
kalem hep yanında dursun ve dersin
gidişatını şimdi yazdıracağım
küçük tabloyla takip et. Olur mu? Şimdi
açıyorum ben de kendi kağıdımı. Boş bir
sayfa açtım ve diyorum ki hücre zarında
madde alışverişleri
hangi prensiplere göre anlatılır ya da
öğrenilir? Şimdi sana önce şöyle bir
soru soracaklar. Diyecekler ki şimdi bir
maddeyi hücreye alırken işte fosfolipit
katmandan ya da taşıyıcı kanallardan ya
da taşıyıcı proteinlerden alabiliyor
musun? Yani bu madde zardan geçebiliyor
mu?
Bu bir.
ya da
zardan geçemeyen
özel
koful içinde geçmek zorunda kalan
maddeler için mi yapıyorsun?
Önce bu soruya cevap vermem lazım.
Sonra zardan geçebilen bu madde
sadece kendi sahip olduğu kinetik
enerjiyle mi hareket ediyor yoksa bir
hücresel enerjiye ihtiyaç var mı?
Mesela ATP gibi pasif taşımada
moleküller kendi hareketleriyle işte
kendi kinetik enerjileriyle hareket
ederken
aktif taşımada ATP'ye ihtiyacın var.
Pasifte
olayımız difüzyon mu yoksa suyun
difüzyonu anlamına gelen suya özgü ozmoz
olayından mı bahsediyorsun?
Difüzyyonda da moleküller
fosfolipit katmandan hiç kimsenin
yardımı olmadan mı geçiyor?
Yoksa bir taşıyıcı yapı bir proteinin
yardımıyla mı geçiyor?
İşte buna bakacaksın. Bu tarafa
geldiğinde zardan geçemeyen madde
ya da bir koful içerisinde geçmek
zorunda olan, çıkmak zorunda olan madde
hücrenin içine doğru mu geliyor
yoksa hücreden dışarı mı atılıyor?
Egzoz dışarı atmak.
Endositozda
fagositoz,
pinositoz gibi temel kavramları
öğreniyorsunuz. Bir de ekstradan
arkadaşlar
reseptör aracılı
endositoz var. Bu da bazen denemelerde,
testlerde karşınıza çıkıyor. Reseptör
aracılı endositoz bir molekülü alırken
zarda reseptörüne bağladıktan sonra
koful oluşturup içeri aldığımız
yöntemlerden bir tanesi. İşte bu ana
tabloyu arkadaşlar
size anlatacağım. kademe kademe
gideceğiz. Her seferinde.
Bakın kağıtta şuradaydı.
Bu mantık vardı. Buna dikkat etmeniz
lazımdı şeklinde cümleler kuracağım.
Şimdi bu bir kenarda kalsın ve konumuza
başlayalım. O zaman ne diyoruz? Hadi
gelin birlikte öğrenelim.
Hücre zarının temel yapısından
bahsederiz. akıcı mozaik zar modeli
vardır deriz. Bunlardan hızlıca
bahsedeyim. Fosfolipit katman var. Bir
layer, iki katman dediğimiz şu şekilde
birbirine dönük fosfolipitler var.
Fosfolipitlerin arasında, üstünde, iç
yüzeyinde proteinler var. Bu proteinler
kanal olabiliyor, taşıyıcı protein
olabiliyor, integral protein olabiliyor.
İçeriden hücre iskeleti dışarıya doğru
başka bir hücreyi bağlayan yapı
olabiliyor.
Bir de hücrenin dışına doğru
karbohidratlar bulunabiliyor. Ama bu
karbohidratlar serbest değil. Ya lipite
bağlı glikolipit, ya proteine bağlı
glikoprotein. İşte bunlarda reseptör,
hücreye kimlik, özgünlük, antijenik yapı
kazandıran yapılar olacak. ya da
haberleşmeyi sağlayan vesaire. Akıcı
mozaik zar modelinde proteinler sürekli
hareket halindedir arkadaşlar. Lütfen
bunu unutmayın. Bitki hücre zarı ve
hayvan hücre zarı arasındaki en temel
farklardan bir tanesi de hayvan
hücrelerinde kolesterol bulunmaları.
Kolesterol zarın akışkanlığı dinamik
yapısı için de önemli arkadaşlar. Bakın
yapıdaki fosfolipit suyu seven bir baş
kısmı hidrofilik yapı. Suyu sevmeyen bir
kuyruk kısmı hidrofobik yapısı var. Bir
sürü protein var. Ve ne dedim?
Karbohidratlar ya lipitlere ya
proteinlere bağlı. Proteinlere bağlıysa
glikoprotein, lipitlere bağlıysa
glikolipit şeklinde. Ve kolesterol zarın
akışkanlığını düzenleyen moleküldür.
Hücre zarı seçici geçirgendir. Önüne her
gelen giremez. Giriyorsa da belli
kurallara göre girecekti. Madde
alışverişlerinde spesifik olarak bunu
söyleyeceğim. Bir madde yağda çözünüyor
ya da yağı çözüyorsa arkadaşlar direkt
fosfolipit katmandan geçecek. Bunlar
için herhangi bir geçite gerek yok ama
suda çözünen bir maddenin geçitlerden
geçmesini, kanallardan geçmesini
beklersiniz. Proteinlerin sayısı ve
dağılımı hücreden hücreye hatta aynı
hücrenin değişik kısımlarında bile
farklılık gösterebilir. Normal şartlarda
arkadaşlar protein oranına baktığınızda
hücre zarının yaklaşık %50 civarındadır.
Ama mitokondri ve kloroplastlarda
elektron taşıma sistemi elemanları vardı
değil mi? ya da ATP sentaz gibi bir
protein. İşte bunlar arkadaşlar protein
oranını çok yüksek değerlere çıkartıyor.
Bu yapılarda hücre zarında proteinler ne
işe yarar? Hücrelerin birbirini
tanıması, enzimsel aktiviteler
gösterilmesi,
bağlanma ki hücre iskelet elemanları
hücreyi hücreye bağlar. Reseptör olarak
işlev yapma. Hücre dışındaki sinyali
hücre içine iletme, içeride birtım
tepkimeler başlatarak hücrenin dış
ortamla madde alışverişi yapmasını
sağlama gibi proteinlerin görevleri var.
Neydi karbohidratlar? Hücre dışına bakan
kısımda protein ya da lipitlere bağlı
halde bulunacaktı. Glikoprotein,
glikolipit, hücrenin birbirini tanıması,
sinyal algılaması, seçici geçirgenliğin
denetlenmesinde
işlev görecekti. Bakın, glikoproteinin
özgünlük, kimlik, antijenik özelliği ile
alakalı sorular soruldu geçmişte.
Bunların da Golgi tarafından özellikle
endoplazmik etkum ve Golgi son şeklini
verdiği için Golgi vurgusu daha çok
yapılır. Golgi tarafından
sentezlendiğini unutmayın. Kolesterol
zarın akışkanlığını düzenler. Zara
sağlamlık ve esneklik verir. Bakın 5
dakika içerisinde bundan üç defa
bahsettik. Çünkü döne döne bu bilgiler
karşınıza çıkacak. Hücre duvarı var bazı
canlılarda. bitkilerde selloz,
mantarlarda çoğunlukla kitin,
bakterilerde peptidoglikan, arkelerde
çok fazla tip olduğu için böyle spesifik
bir isim vermiyoruz ama işte bazılarında
psodopeptidoglikan yapı var şeklinde
ifadeler kullanabiliyoruz.
Ne yapıyor? Zara desteklik sağlıyor. Az
yoğun ortamda bir canlının hayatta
kalabilmesini sağlıyor. Bu ne demek?
Birazdan söyleyeceğim. Eğer siz
hipotonik bir ortamda bir hücreyi
tutarsanız hücrenin içerisine su
girecek. Ve belli bir yerden sonra eğer
çeperi yoksa patlayacak. Çeper varsa
yani hücre duvarı varsa işte bu
patlamaya engel olacak. Arkadaşlar bakın
hücre zarındaki proteinlerin
hareketliliği ile alakalı birtım
deneyler yapılmış. Bu deneyler aslında
bir ÖSYM sorusuydu. Fare ve insan
hücreleri kaynaştırılarak yapılıyor
arkadaşlar ve hibrit meles hücre
üretiliyor. Tabii ki bu zar özelinde bir
deney. Bu zarın içerisindeki maddeler
yer değiştiriyor ve hani mantık olarak
işte t = 0 anında bir x bölgesinde
bulunan şey t = 2 anında bir y
bölgesinde karşımıza çıkıyor. Bu da
zarların arkadaşlar rastgele dağılım
gösteren proteinlere sahip olduğunu ve
bu proteinlerin hareket ettiğini bize
kanıtlayan bir çalışma oluyor. Burada
güzel bir tablo var arkadaşlar. Hem
prokaryotları hem de ökaryotları sahip
olduğu özelliklere göre değerlendiriyor.
Kim nerede var? Bunların hepsinden
arkadaşlar tek bahsettik. Mesela
kloroplast ifadesi. Bakın kloroplast
prokaryotlarda olmaz. protistalar
içerisinde alk gibi, öglena gibi
canlılarda bulunabilir. Mantarların
tamamı heteretroftur. Tamarazit bitkiler
hariç hepsinde bulunur. Hayvanlarda
bulunmaz şeklinde arkadaşlar
bilgilerinizi buradan
tazeleyebilirsiniz. Şimdi hücre zarında
madde geçleri başlığını artık gönül
rahatlığıyla inceleyebiliriz. Az önce
yazdığımız kağıdı şöyle bir gözünüzün
görebileceği yere koyun arkadaşlar ve
beni takip edin. Zardan maddeler
kafalarına göre geçemezler. Hücre zarı
seçici geçirgendir. Peki hocam içeriye
alınacak ya da dışarıya atılacak
maddenin derişimi, büyüklüğü, suda ya da
yağda çözünmesi, yükü vesaire bunlar çok
kıymetli, çok önemli. Ve diyorsun ki
eğer ben
madde alışverişi tablosu hazırlayacaksam
ilk sorum bu madde zardan geçebiliyor
mu, geçemiyor mu? Buna bakarım.
zardan geçebiliyorsa, zardan
geçebiliyorsa
hücresel enerji harcamıyorsa pasif,
harcıyorsa aktif taşıma olarak
adlandırırım. Peki bak zardan geçecek,
geçemeyecek.
Geçerken hücresel enerji harcamayacak,
hücresel enerji harcayacak. Hocam
endositoz ve egzostitoz için enerji
harcar harcamaz demedik çünkü harcanır.
Burada bir bedel ödemen lazım. Bir dur
oraya kadar gitme.
Pasifte difüzyon mu yoksa suyun
difüzyonundan mı bahsediyorsun? Buna
bakacaktın. Difüzyyonda da bir madde
doğrudan fosfolipit katmandan girip
çıkabiliyorsa
biz buna basit difüzyon diyeceğiz. Yok
hocam bu madde özel proteinler, taşıyıcı
proteinler aracılığıyla girip çıkıyorsa
biz buna kolaylaşmış difüzyon diyeceğiz.
Peki bu bir kalsın.
Şimdi öğrencim burada tabii dersi benden
önce dinledi. Öğretmeninden notlar aldı.
okulda güzel bir temel attı ve kendi
kafasından şöyle bir soru sordu. Ya
hocam biz aktif taşımada da ama protein
kullanıyoruz. Yani bunun ayrımını nasıl
yapacağız peki?
Derişim farkı ve ATP vardı değil mi?
Difüzyyonda çoktan aza, aktif taşımada
ise ya eşitliği bozacak yönde ya da
azdan çoğa doğru hareket yapılır. Yani
pasif taşıma neymiş? Maddelerin çoktan
aza doğru hareket ettiği, hücresel bir
enerjiye ihtiyaç duyulmayan moleküllerin
kendi kinetik enerjisiyle yaptığı iş
hareket. Tamam. Süper. Hocam hücre
zarından madde geçişi ile ilgili bir
şeyler söyledin az önce. Onları bir
toparlayalım. Yağda çözünenler
çözünemeyenlere göre, yağı çözenler
çözemeyenlere göre, küçük moleküller
büyük moleküllere göre, nötr maddeler
iyonlara göre daha hızlı hareket
ederler. Arkadaşlar böyle küçük temel
kurallarımız var. Pasif taşımada kinetik
enerji ön plandaydı.
Sıcaklıkla kinetik enerjiyi düşünelim o
zaman. Bir molekülün sıcaklığını
arttırırsanız kinetik enerjisi ne olur?
Artar. Demek ki pasif taşımada
bir molekülün hızını arttırabilmek için
ortama sıcaklığını arttırsanız
bu bir yere kadar olumlu karşılanabilir.
Doğru mu? Evet hocam. Neden bir yere
kadar dedim?
Basit difüzyon kolaylaştırmış difüzyon.
Kolaylaştırmış difzyonda ne var? Protein
var. Proteinler sıcaklıktan etkilenir
mi? etkilenir. O zaman orada dikkat
edeceksin. Ama burada bir mürekkep
damlasını suyun içerisine damlattın. Bu
basit füzyon.
Ya da kolonyayı aldın odanın bir
kenarına döktün. Oradan etrafa dağıldı.
E basit di füzyon. Nerede? Burada
taşıyıcı protein mi var? Yok. O zaman
burada sıcaklığı arttırdığında hızı
arttırırsın ve hani ya bir protein
yapısı bozulur mu diye de korkmazsın.
Hocam kolaylaşmış difüzyonda sıcaklıkla
hız artmıyor mu? artıyor ama belli bir
yere kadar dikkat edeceksin. Çünkü
taşıyıcı protein yapısını bozarsan artık
difüzyondan vesaire bahsedemezsin ki
zaten. Şimdi bir çözeltideki çözünenler
sıvının her tarafına eşit olarak
yayıldıktan sonra dahi hareketlerine
devam eder. Bu ne demek biliyor musunuz?
Yani geçişler arkadaşlar devam edecektir
ama difüzyonda öyle derişim farkı
yaratmazsın.
Difüzyonun mantığı eşitlemeye
çalışmaktır.
Çoktan aza geç. Her iki tarafının da
derişimini eşitlemeye çalış. Aslında
temel mantığı budur. Ama aktif taşımada
sürekli bir fark yaratma mantığı var.
Sürekli hani bu tarafta daha çok olsun
ya da bu tarafta daha az olsun mantığı
var. Suda çözünmeyen maddeler su içinde
yayılmaz. Mesela nişasta molekülleri bir
yerden sonra arkadaşlar çökecektir.
Homojen bir şekilde dağılmayacaktır.
Pasif taşımanın özelliklerine geçelim
hemen tekrar. Hocam söylediğimiz her şey
burada var. Hücresel enerji yok.
Çözünenler çok yoğun olduğu ortamdan az
yoğun olduğu ortama doğru hareket eder.
Çözücüler örneğin su az yoğun ortamdan
çok yoğun ortama doğru hareket eder. Bu
ne demek? Bak şimdi bu şu demek. Ozmozda
söyleyeceğim. Diyelim ki burada %80
sükroz var. Burada da %20 sükroz var. Su
nereden nereye hareket eder? 80'den
20'ye mi? Saçmalama hocam.
Orada 80 sükroz varsa 20 su var. Çünkü
bu yüde. Burada da 80 su var. Öyleyse su
bu tarafa doğru hareket eder. Bunu
söylüyor bak. Az yoğun ortamdan, suyun
az olduğu ortamdan demiyor. Az yoğun
ortamdan çok yoğun ortama doğru su
hareket ediyor diyor. ATP aramadığım
için canlı cansız ortamlarda
gözlenebilir. Hücre zarında taşıyıcı
proteinler kullanılmadan gerçekleşiyorsa
buna basit difüzyon denir. Ama eğer
kullanılıyorsa ona da kolaylaştırılmış
difüzyon denir. Difüzyon ve ozmoz olarak
ikiye ayrılır. Tekrar söyleyelim.
Difüzyon kendi içerisinde basit
difüzyon. Kolaylaşmış difüzyon olmak
üzere iki aylık. Arkadaşlar kolaylaşmış
difüzyonu okulda görmemiş olabilirsiniz
ama ben burada konu bütünlüğünü sağlamak
açısından anlatmayı tercih ediyorum.
Bence anlatılmalı bu. Burada bir şekilde
kalsın. Pasif taşıma ile ilgili
aşağıdaki ifadelerden hangisi
söylenebilir? Taşıma için gerekli enerji
ATP'den sağlanmaz. Maddeler çoktan aza
doğru hareket eder. Canlı cansız
ortamlarda görülebilir. Taşıyıcı
proteinler kullanılmadan gerçekleşmez
demiş. Hocam gerçekleşir. Nedir? Basit
difüzyon varsa gerçekleşir. Tekrar
söyleyelim. Bir madde fosfolipit
katmandan geçiyor, çıkıyorsa bu basit
difüzyondur. Özel bir taşıyıcı molekül,
taşıyıcı protein kullanıyorsa bu da
kolaylaştırmış difüzyondur. Sadece büyük
moleküllerin değil zardan geçebilecek
moleküllerin taşınmasını sağlar. Burada
bir mola verelim. Yeni başlık gibi ama
söylediğimiz şeyleri tekrar edeceğiz.
Belki 5 kere 10 kere aynı şeyleri
duyacaksınız arkadaşlar. Merak etmeyin.
Bu konu çok güzel oturacak. Hadi bir
mola.